as many of you know the rounded apple  watch series 7 design caused a ton of  controversy last year because literally  everyone was expecting a new flat sided  redesign to happen john prosser finally  revealed a huge secret about those boxy  apple watch renders that he kept hidden  from all of us the entire time he ended  up revealing the original renders from  his sources those renders showed not one  but two apple watch designs the larger  one on the right was most likely meant  to be a brand new extra series 8 model i  believe the new boxy design is meant to  be marketed as a pro model that's going  to be more expensive and offer the  highest end features they've gotta give  it a redesign that looks nothing like  every apple watch that they've ever made  before because of the flat display glass  which will allow them to throw in a  larger battery and they can offer it in  titanium only which will make it more  tough